warzone goes back to the 1980s this is
confirmed by treyarch
and now we're here to talk about every
other change coming to warzone
i'm here with aaron sampson the two of
us were able to check out a
preview event for the upcoming season
three
and war zone which is why you're here
erin let's talk about
what's going on with warzone okay so we
actually now know
everything that's gonna happen in
warzone we're about a week ahead of the
rest of the
public right now so we don't actually
know what you will already know by the
time this video comes out
so we're just going to tell you
everything and if there's things that
you know already that's great if there's
things that you don't know hopefully we
are going to tell you something new
i'd like to start off by talking to our
modern warfare audience in a
q a session at the end of this
presentation they
did pretty much confirm that modern
warfare is done
[Music]
they're not thinking about it anymore
and kind of the way we were looking at
this before where you have to take
captain price's
story ending at face value is true
so that's that's over with and their
brains are almost 100 on cold war
now verdance 84 is a new war zone map
and it is
completely related to cold war it has
cold wars locations
it's sounds like it's almost it's like a
reskin uh they said
they're touching almost every aspect of
the map there's a lot of new
places on the maps and there's also a
lot of redone places but the big
question is how are we going to get
there that is a lot of what is rolling
out this week
so that is going to happen in four
phases phase one is escalation protocol
which is zombies going across the map
that is what people are seeing now um
when it first happened we actually
thought it might have been a mistake
it almost looked a little buggy but nope
that is that's what's going on there's
gonna be zombies leaving behind
corruption zones those corruption zones
will spread from the locations where the
zombies used to be we
recently saw one over at ship and prison
it turns players into zombies if you die
in the gas
we tested it though you can't you can't
win that way if your team dies
and you're a zombie out in the gas you
still lose so
you can't cheat by doing it that way
then there's phase two the destruction
of her dance
which is what everybody's been waiting
for so there is a countdown clock
the corruption zones expand players have
to survive in this mode
but guess what there's nothing you can
do about it the map's gonna get nuked no
matter what you do
sorry if you thought you could save the
world you can't verdance is done
so the map gets nuked and everybody's
off of it you can't go to that map for a
little while
that kicks off phase three the rebirth
island nuke event where one lucky player
gets to fire off the nuke that just
destroyed verdansk so everybody gets
transported to rebirth island
you're fighting on rebirth island to set
off a nuke but only one player gets to
do it something
i should add about these two nuke events
now there's there's two nuke events
one of them is like a plague event
leading into a nuke event is that these
will be limited time modes they will
only take place for approximately two
hours each and then it's
done so if you weren't there you're not
going to see it you can probably watch
it on youtube
but you will not get to experience it so
once the nuke is then fired off
from rebirth island by one player that
starts the last phase where everybody
gets instantly transported to verdansk84
we were trying to figure this out before
like how does a duke take people back in
time
they're taking the easy way out it just
narratively goes back in time it's like
yup for dance is gone boom it's done
there's no like zombie portals or
anything like that you just get rewound
literally back into time and you are in
for dance 84.
the current warzone modern warfare map
is done it's not coming back from what
they've said
now they say that maybe someday it'll
come back into rotation but from what
they've told us
it's it's completely over which is good
or bad depending on what you're looking
for but
i think people have been wanting a map
refresh for a very long time
and this map refresh is very extensive
that overhaul consists of a couple of
different things so we'll go through
these one at a time so for dancing 84 is
a very different map it
is a brightly colored 80s map we had a
great youtube comment where somebody is
worried it was going to be like
depressing stalinist russia but it's not
it's it's colorful 80s
it's much more forested than the map
previously was
but the force are offset by the downtown
area is way less dense so they've kind
of
they've thinned out the buildings but
they've thickened all the foliage around
it
so different colors different
environment and
you know a few less buildings now richie
you took a very extensive look at the
new locations why don't you go into that
sure got a whole list of things that are
coming back
things that are new so let's get right
into it so we saw
the superstore which looked you know
like a functional store not so abandoned
we saw the duga array from cold war and
it's really
tall it's a really big point of interest
and you can get to the tippy top of it
and fight
on the very top parts of the antenna it
looked pretty cool
uh according to the all the gameplay we
saw we also saw things that were
confirmed from that leaked video
like the dam which is now just a big
bridge
uh there is no dam structure but what's
fun about this is that behind the
the dam or the bridge now they
incorporated where the lake was
they incorporated the summit map the
classic black ops map
it's not really iced over it's kind of
it's a little more
like earth tone colors but the layout is
mostly there and the gondolas are
actually
functional they're not just cosmetic
anymore so it'll be fun you can cross
over to
sort of where the docks currently are
those new docks they added
that might have been a tease for that
whole situation because instead of the
lake
it is now summit the airport is also
not destroyed it is a two-layer
functional building now
and they they they showed off how people
at the airport control tower
usually just like to hold that zone in
snipe and that now you can combat that
by being on the second floor of the
airport
so we saw visuals of that it's looking
good it's looking you know
like an actual airport not just a rubble
destroyed mess
other areas that have been replaced are
uh or added in
one is an old mine that is behind
the airport there's kind of there's a
lot of open spaces in verdansk and
they're
trying to combat that with things like
this they were trying to make a better
transition from dam
to the airport basically so they've done
some thinking about
map transitions and how to get from
point a to point b without covering
huge amounts of open ground that's true
because another area they talked about
and i'm excited mostly for this one is
outside of gulag
from gulag to downtown it's kind of a
grassy knoll area
very open in that area they added the
standoff map from black ops 2.
so it's going to be an 80s verdance
version of
standoff which is also going to be the
6v6 map
coming back to cold war proper this is
exciting to see because it's also
filling the spaces where there was just
nothing to do except i
other areas of interest are the quarry
which is
pretty similar looking but it is now a
salt mine so
instead of a big dip in the ground like
that that crater it's a little more
level and it's
salt mines and they also mentioned that
every area within the quarry all every
door is openable
there were some buildings that you
couldn't just get into you can kind of
hide behind but
not get into they've unlocked every door
they said also instead of those big
cylindrical silos
uh i couldn't pinpoint where on the map
but there's a few areas with these silos
one of these areas is going to be
replaced with an airport
factory so it's just like you know uh uh
it's it's a pretty medium-sized area
with just you know
parts of airplanes everywhere a lot of
places to take cover
uh so that'll be showing up too also
mentioned in the presentation
private matches are coming to rebirth
island so the same way you can have a
private match with 50 people or more in
war zone
they've applied that to the rebirth map
and last but not least you guys we've
got some gulag news currently it is
modeled after the new town map
but in this presentation they announced
that it will soon be updated to fit the
standoff map
so i don't know what part of standoff is
gonna be how big it's gonna be
but they did tease that information
coming up soon this current google log
isn't really fair and uh speaking of
fair erin i think you have some more
news on
on balancing warzone what do you got so
everybody knows that the ffar is
unbalanced it's really obvious
that that's the case devs were asked
this question
during our qa session and what they said
was yes the ffar is unbalanced it
leads too much into the smg territory
which is a little confusing because
smgs are usually good at middle to close
range and the ffr is
like very dominant at long ranges but
they indicated that there was going to
be a nerf the question is
is their mind in the right place for how
the gun needs to be nerfed
you have to also balance that with
there's a lot of skins coming this
season and one of those skins was the
ffar skin
there's some pretty crazy looking ones
um that you you know cold war players
will enjoy
but people don't trust activision you
know one of the leading theories is that
the gun is unbalanced because they're
trying to sell skins for it
so you're gonna have to balance your
level of trust with are they gonna nerf
it correctly with their desire to
to sell things for it the smg comment
means maybe it'll get
nerfed at close range so we'll just have
to see on that one so those are the
things we were able to check out at this
presentation
there's a lot to unpack here so we want
to throw it back to you guys and ask if
you're ready to leave modern day
verdansk
we're going back to the 80s now and
there's no sign that we'll return
so we got to put the modern warfare
story behind us let us know how you feel
about that in the comments
and we'll see you next time thanks for
[Music]
watching
[Music]
you